what is happening reject nation greg and
john here
ghostbusters afterlife has released a
little teaser here
mini puffs character reveal ghostbusters
afterlife is a movie that i i keep
forgetting kind of exists
it's like every time i hear about it i'm
excited every time i see something of it
i'm like ooh
i'm really looking forward to it but for
some reason i kind of forget about this
movie from time to time
you know i don't blame you there's a
whole lot else going on in the public
eye there's a whole lot of bigger movies
happening
right now speaking of which we got to
keep this one really short today because
uh we have an interview to do
i don't know how much i can say we have
an interview to do with a screenwriter
for
one of the most anticipated movies
that's coming out in the next few weeks
so that's in like 20 minutes i gotta
shoot this and then
edit it super quick right after let's
see what this clip
is of ghostbusters afterlife
[Music]
i know right
ah
[Music]
no pillsbury doughboys
[Music]
what the hell
[Applause]
is this this looks
new yeah doesn't it yeah
no i'm saying like this there's
something that this footage looks like
it was recently filmed
he looks different than he did in the
trailer i mean
paul rudd's very hard to look different
in age because the guys looked the same
age for 45 years
there's some slight differences in his
hair and you know i'm not saying this is
the case but you know how there was zack
snyder's justice league which had a much
darker lighting
and then you got the jaw sweden cup
which really punched up everything if
you look at the ghostbusters afterlife
trailer which has a much darker tint to
it and then you see this footage
it has a little bit of that flavor to it
like this doesn't look like it's shot by
the same person
yeah it's much brighter paul rudd's beer
is a little more full
so maybe they could have shot this later
or something more punched in
if anything this feels like an ad they
shot for ghostbusters
afterlife yeah to remind us about it
without having to unveil new footage
yeah just yeah just get a very
recognizable motif of the original movie
with the stay puft marshmallow man and
then just go to town with some kind of
demented set piece that doesn't need to
make any sense
yeah yeah because i mean it's definitely
the promissory of
a familiar piece and also be like just
demented things are going to be
happening all across this movie
you know not just ghost stuff but like
yeah more mischief little things brought
to life
i think tonally it captures a good
amount of ghostbusters
the mysterious horror or something
happening yet with the wonder and
astonishment like paul rudd starts off
as like what the
hell to oh you're wow and then oh my god
this is terrifying yeah
which is kind of like the opening of
ghostbusters encompassed in a 50-second
video
at a walmart or something or like or a
little turtle town or whatever the hell
it literally looks like the target is
down there
yeah right and it's exciting to see like
the stay puft marshmallow man coming
back but you know like playing on the
nostalgia factor for it
i don't want it to just be a nostalgia
fest i think that's kind of the con like
a little bit of nostalgia can go a long
way
but too much nostalgia can be uh
uninspiring
and overbearing and overbearing
absolutely this does feel so
this doesn't feel like it's from the
movie it feels very very isolated or at
very least
heavily heavily edited and smooshed
together to be just yeah
quick bite it feels like the kind of
commercial they'd play
keep a lookout for the trailer or
something that plays before amc movies
tie-in with actual marshmallows stay
puft was like a real company
i mean there's a whole bunch of like
yeah exactly i mean there's a whole
bunch of
other products in here but they're not
really getting close-ups on their names
not just a lot of
jell-o just enough to fund the movie
yeah i mean overall i still found this
to be a pretty charming clip like i said
tonally spiritually
it was capturing the opening scene of
ghostbusters one but in
a 50-second ad yeah so guys
what do you think are you excited for
this film do you think it'll be better
than the 2016.
answer the call baby answer the call
leave your thoughts down below i'm
excited to see um
paul rudd embody all
the paul rudd and all the all the
ghostbusters he's
he's like a teacher seismologist yeah
yeah
it's a good match for being like the
combination of
of uh bill murray and harold ramos well
let's see what's going on
catch you guys soon subscribe hit that
like button thanks for being here